Elizabeth Warren finally comes under
attack and Joe Biden continues to mumble
as Democratic panic sets in I'm Ben
Shapiro this is the Ben Shapiro show so
what did I miss guys the Ben Shapiro
show is sponsored by expressvpn protect
your online privacy today at expressvpn
dot-com
slash fun well I will tell you that
watching the Democratic debates from
abroad um it's kind of wild namely
because you're not really in the middle
of it obviously you are very far away
but also because of the time delay so
that means that the democratic debate
ended in Israel about six a Israel time
which made for a bit of a long night a
bit of a fraught night I mean if you
think that Democratic debates put you to
sleep try watching them at 4:00 a.m. I
mean that that will definitely make you
want to hang yourself but here's the
truth if you're a Democrat and you watch
that debate you got to be a little bit
suicidal after watching that debate
because it just made the Democrats look
bad right now Joe Biden remains the sort
of national frontrunner according to the
Real Clear Politics polling average but
Elizabeth Warren has pulled into the
lead in both Iowa and New Hampshire
where she has a slight lead in Iowa over
both Bernie Sanders and Joe Biden and in
New Hampshire she has a very slight lead
over Joe Biden but Elizabeth Warren was
nothing to write home about last night
she really was not she looked weak
because guess what Elizabeth Warren is
running as this wild-eyed progressive
but she doesn't believe any of this
stuff and so she refuses to actually
save the stuff out loud if she were a
true believer like Bernie Sanders she
just saved the stuff out loud which by
the way is one reason why Ilhan Omar and
AOC and Rasheeda Talib are all talking
about endorsing not Elizabeth Warren
but endorsing Bernie Sanders that also
shows up their sort of street cred if
they did endorsed Elizabeth Warren then
they'd have to ride that hobbyhorse all
the way to the election if they endorsed
Bernie Sanders who's going nowhere then
they get to look completely woke and
completely committed without actually
having to invest any time or effort
campaigning for somebody during the
primary season end or general election
with that said the debate last night
really had a couple of themes themed
number one Elizabeth Warren under attack
is not a strong candidate Elizabeth
Warren is great when she is on her
talking points she's sort of like MIT
Romney this way on the talking points
good pushed off the talking points not
so good
because once she was pushed off her
talking points she looked pretty weak
last night Joe Biden meanwhile he's
his prime he's obviously past his prime
he sort of late-stage Muhammad Ali in in
his boxing career and he's losing to
fighters he shouldn't lose to and you
can see this during the debates during
every exchange he would sort of have one
solid comeback and then he'd sort of
collapse in on himself like a dying star
because he didn't have a lot beyond that
he can't sustain for a very long period
of time in these debates so he has sort
of a strong first move and then hmm and
he sort of falls over okay so that was
another theme of the night the the
biggest theme of the night probably is
that all of the moderates who actually
did a lot of damage against the
progressive candidates last night the
Bernie Sanders is in the Elizabeth
Warren's and the and and and some of the
other more radical Candis like bitter a
rock the the sort of moderate wing of
the Democratic Party they make the
progressives look bad but they're not
picking up any support inside the
Democratic Party because the among the
most passionate part of the Democratic
Party is that woke based that social
justice warrior base and so that means
they're not going anywhere
even if they are making some pretty good
points now Joe Biden was supposed to be
the marriage of these two things right
he was supposed to bring along the wolf
progressive base because of his time
with Barack Obama that great progressive
hero and at the same time he was
supposed to bring moderates from Ohio
and Wisconsin and Pennsylvania and
Michigan he was supposed to bring all
these blue-collar workers who could have
voted for Bernie but didn't vote for
Hillary and then sort of voted for Trump
and he was supposed to be the great
reach out candidate to those candidates
but he appears weak and this is leading
to a sort of vacuum at the top of the
Democratic field and if you are a
political pundit you're starting to see
this panic set in in fact you could see
it last night where commentators on
MSNBC were basically lamenting that
Elizabeth Warren was so weak but first
let's talk about hiring at your company
okay the fact is that you may have great
people working at your company or you
may have not great people working at
your company and you constantly need to
upgrade like for example let's say that
you had an employee who came in here
every morning and the clips just weren't
ready but you know what you love the guy
and so you keep them around until you
can find somebody better via zip record
that's talking about you call them
talking about just someone completely
who's not Colton okay good check out zip
recruiter com
the reason you check out super couriers
they make it incredibly incredibly easy
to find great employees four out of five
employers who post on zip recruiting
quality candidate within the very first
day and it's very important to find a
quality candidate I mean you don't wanna
be sitting around with second-rate
employees again not talking about Colton
here see why zip recruiter is effective
for businesses of all size try zip
recruiter for free at this exclusive web
address zip recruiter comm slash daily
wire that is zip recruiter comm slash
daily wear saves you all sorts of time
and when you have second-rate employees
again not Colton when you have
second-rate employees then you want to
make sure that you replace them
forthwith so they're not wasting a lot
of time and money
zip recorded comm slash daily wire and
try them out for free zip recruiter is
the smartest way to hire a here are the
commentators on an MSNBC panel last
night talking about how she looked at
Elizabeth Warren looked petulant how she
didn't have good answers to her
questions here it is she was annoyed
because she came under attack and she
was under she came under a lot of attack
for the Medicare for all on the Medicare
for all question and the question of
which he raised taxes and she has a
formula that she sticks to she says
costs will go down for the middle class
she will not say the taxes will go up
but other costs will come down as as
Bernie Sanders says she just won't go
there and she was pummeled for it it
makes it looks like she's hiding
yeah Chris Hayes comes out and he says
the same thing he says there has to be
some sort of demand here for an on Biden
alternative to Warren and Sanders
because this is week T man there's just
not a lot here he says I think there's a
sort of interesting theory of the case
that revolves around Pete Buddha judge
and also I think to a certain extent a
mcComish R which is the idea that there
is some vacuum and demand for a kind of
non Biden alternative to Warren and
Sanders and I think that that's driven a
lot of the thinking about the race I
think it's driving the way that people
think about where they fit the question
is is there space and this is the big
question for the race right now right is
there space for someone who who isn't
Joe Biden to be in there CNN's John King
who obviously is a member of the most
trusted name in news he comes out and he
says it's pretty obvious that Warren and
Biden as the frontrunners are also
pretty weak frontrunner without a doubt
I agree that the other candidates on
that stage clearly
thought it was in their best interest to
go after Elizabeth Warren to go after
her on Medicare for all to go after her
economic views to go after her more
broadly and the idea that they think
especially from the moderates too far
left will take the country in a way that
you can't win here in Ohio and across
the Midwest the Vice President was
almost an afterthought Joe Biden in this
debate which is striking in that the
early debates people viewed him as the
front-runner so bottom line is the
Democrats in members of the media but I
repeat myself they're starting to look
at this field and say this does not look
nearly as strong as we thought it was
going to look when this field was
shaping up now there was one area in
which they were all unified and this
demonstrates why the impeachment effort
is being done right here and right now
the Democrats do not have the goods from
Pietschmann right now when I say they
don't have the goods for impeachment
right now I mean Nancy Pelosi will not
even bring up the formal opening of an
impeachment inquiry up for vote she
won't even bring it up right why won't
she do that because there's no upside
for her she's afraid Democrats might
vote it down she doesn't have the votes
for it quite yet so why not sort of sit
around let the impeachment inquiry move
forward and then as evidence comes out
then you move forward with the
impeachment inquiry according to the
hill Pelosi said on Tuesday she will not
stage a vote on the House floor to
officially launch an impeachment inquiry
into President Trump
she knows no such vote would take place
right so the Democrats don't actually
have the momentum yet with regard to
impeachment but they are relying very
heavily on impeachment why because when
it comes to their own ideas their own
ideas are garbage the only thing that
they have in common and the real
rallying point is that they think Trump
sucks and you could see that last night
and everything the Democrats were saying
it began with Elizabeth Warren who said
she called for Trump's impeachment as
soon as the Mullen report came out
because she wanted to prevent further
impeachable offenses impeachment is the
way that we establish that this man will
not be permitted to break the law over
and over without consequences this is
about Donald Trump but understand it's
about the next president and the next
president and the next president and the
future of this country the impeachment
must go forward thank you sir so there
you have Elizabeth Warren saying oh well
you know we have to stop Trump from
breaking the law now does Elizabeth
Warren really care about law breaking by
presidents no Barack Obama
was droning American citizens overseas
and she had nothing to say about that
Barack Obama was presiding over an IRS
that was targeting his political
opponents nothing to say about that she
didn't care about the rule of law
obviously what Elizabeth Warren does
care about is this unifying feature
inside the Democratic Party and so this
part of the debate the early part of the
debate turned into a game of
one-upsmanship where the Democrats were
like not only is Donald Trump a bad man
he's the worst man the worst kind of man
and that's how you get Joe Biden who's
been subjected to Trump's attacks on his
purported corruption inside Ukraine
which we got to in a second Joe Biden
saying that Trump is quote the most
corrupt president in modern history and
in all of our history this President and
I agree with Bernie senator Sanders is
the most corrupt president in modern
history and I think all of our history
and the fact is that this president
knighted States has gone so far as to
say since this latest event that in fact
he will not cooperate in any way at all
well not less any witnesses are not
provided information will not do
anything to cooperate with the
impeachment they have no choice but to
move so that's Joe Biden playing
one-upsmanship with Elizabeth Warren
they have no choice but to move and then
you had come out let Harris who came out
after that and then she actually said
that Trump is not only the most corrupt
he is also the most unpatriotic so they
just keep adding on descriptors Kamala
Harris is always the person who goes too
far at the party and Kamala Harris will
always go too far at the party she's
just not drinking she's not playing beer
pong she's playing like vodka pong right
like that it doesn't it doesn't matter
what you are doing come on the Harris
will go one step further now the only
honest take on the impeachment stuff
happened from Tulsi Gabbard Tulsi
finally made the debate and she was
interesting at least she provided a
level of interest the congresswoman from
Hawaii
she said that impeachment is appears to
be partisan at this point which of
course is true here is Tulsi Gabbard
saying a true thing on stage which we're
not allowed to say if impeachment is
driven by these hyper partisan interests
it will only further divide an already
terribly divided country unfortunately
this is what we've already seen play out
as calls for impeachment really began
shortly after Trump won his election and
as unhappy as that may make us as
Democrats he won that election in 2006
rabbit OC is sort of the is sort of the
scold at the party nobody wants to hang
out with Tulsi because Tulsi is saying
through things instead everybody was
high off their own fumes I mean their
hotboxing themselves inside the their
hotboxing themselves inside the VW bug
getting high off the fumes of their own
farts about President Trump being
impeach okay so the debate starts off
with that level of unity and then it
quickly begins to degrade it quickly
begins to devolve but first let's talk
about how you get up in the morning and
you do your shaving and you do your
toiletries but do you know the best
products to use for that stuff I mean
you normally head on over to the Rite
Aid or to the CVS and you pick up sort
of whatever's on the shelf after
shopping for half an hour instead what
you could be doing is receiving the best
products in the mail on demand and this
is where Dollar Shave Club comes in
Dollar Shave Club helps make your life
easier they take away the guesswork and
they guarantee quality shaving products
it's way more than just razors dollar
shave club has you covered head to toe
they've got everything you need to
shower shave style your hair brush your
teeth I particularly love their amber
lavender body cleanser it is so calming
and soothing Dollar Shave Club keeps you
automatically stocked up on the products
you use you get what you want whenever
you need it whether that's once a month
or a few times a year and you're not
gonna have to waste your time at one of
those drugstore is trying to shop around
35 different overpriced options right
now you can put the quality of Dollar
Shave club's products to the test their
ultimate shave starter set has basically
everything you need for an amazing shave
like the executive razor shave butter
prep scrub post shave do the best part
is you can drive for just five bucks
after that the restock box ships regular
size products at regular prices so get
that ultimate starter set for just five
bucks at dollarshaveclub.com slash pen
that's dollarshaveclub.com slash men go
check them out right now
dollarshaveclub.com been so Joe Biden is
asked I know it's unbelievable he
actually is asked about the possibility
of corruption here is Anderson Cooper
asking Joe Biden about hunter Biden and
corruption inside Ukraine my question is
if it's not OK for a president's family
to be involved in foreign businesses why
was it ok for your son when you were
vice president vice-president Biden
look my son did nothing wrong I did
nothing wrong I carried out the policy
of the United States government in
rooting out corruption in
in Ukraine and then that's what we
should be focusing on and what I wanted
to make a point about it I my son's
statement speaks for himself he spoke
about it today my son statement speaks
for itself what I think is important is
we focus on why it's so important and
remove this man from office okay there's
only one problem with what joe biden is
saying right there which is that hunter
biden has already admitted his own poor
judgment in getting involved in ukraine
he admitted that the only reason he was
involved is because of his daddy's name
he said in retrospect look I think it
was poor judgment on my part right I
think it was poor judgment because I
don't believe now and I look back on it
I know there was nothing wrong at all
I gave a hook to some very unethical
people to act in illegal ways to try and
do some harm to my father that's where I
made a mistake
he said I'd do it today I do anything
improper no not in any way not in way
whatsoever
but he was asked about whether his last
name being Biden was what led him to get
the job at Purisima in Ukraine he said I
don't know I don't know and then he was
asked you know what about your last name
being Biden didn't that did that help
you write is it if your last name one
bite and would you've gotten the jobs
it's probably not in retrospect he says
but that I don't think there's a lot of
things that would have happened in my
life and my last name wasn't Biden
uh-huh so Joe Biden his protestations
are a little bit too much on this issue
but the popular line of the night is
that Donald Trump is incredibly corrupt
and Joe Biden is pure as the driven snow
cory booker mr. angry eyes he packed his
angry eyes for this debate like mr.
Potato Head and he came out and he said
how dare the moderators even ask this
question how dare they even ask this
question Cory Booker is Jack Nicholson
in the shining man the dude just over
acts
I mean chewing the scenery almost
literally chewing the scenery like there
was one point in this debate or a query
Booker actually went over to the to the
step-and-repeat in the back of the stage
tore off a piece and began chewing it
and swallowing it was real weird so Cory
Booker
he's a how dare you people ask Joe Biden
the most honorable of all human beings
about this sort of stuff
I remember when Cory Booker was calling
Joe Biden a racist that was like two
months ago anyway here's Cory Booker I'm
having deja vu all over again first of
all because I saw this play in 2016's
election we are literally using Donald
Trump's lies and the second issue
cover on this stage is elevating ally
and attacking a statesman that was so
offensive he should not have to defend
ourselves and the only person sitting at
home that was enjoying that was Donald
Trump seeing that were distracting from
his malfeasance and that's selling out
of his office yes Cory Booker I'm sure
that CNN is doing the dirty work of
Donald Trump I'm sure that that is
exactly what they are trying to do they
just lent the first 15 minutes of the
debate to why Donald Trump is a very bad
bad orange man very bad in orange and
why he should be impeached but what
they're really trying to do is Donald
Trump's dirty work and even asking Joe
Biden about the corruption allegations
that was not the only attack on Joe
Biden of course Biden was asked about
his health as well because he was 1
million years old and so Erin Burnett
asked Biden about this it didn't go
fantastically well for Joe Biden Vice
President Biden if you're elected you
will turn 80 during your first term last
month former President Jimmy Carter said
he could not have undertaken the duties
of the presidency at 80 years old why
are you so sure that you can because
I've watched it I know what the job is
I've been engaged look one of the
reasons I am running is because of my
age in my experience with it comes
wisdom
we need someone to take office this time
around who on day one can stand on the
world stage command the respect of world
leaders from Putin to our allies and
know exactly what has to be done to get
this country back on track okay well
that is a riff on the Reagan line about
not letting youth and inexperience be
the in obstacle to the presidency when
he was debating Walter Mondale but is it
really effective for Joe Biden no
because Reagan actually looked like he
was still awake in 1984 whereas Joe
Biden looks like he has been asleep for
at least the last two and a half years
and here's the thing that Biden Biden
really quickly in this debate faded into
the woodwork Biden was not the central
issue who's clear to everybody on the
stage that Elizabeth Warren is now the
front-runner in this campaign and so the
question was how could she take incoming
i jo Biden in the last couple of debates
has taken incoming and she was kind of
okay
but he had his moments that were bad but
overall he was kind of okay have you
been brutal he would have sunk down into
the single digits in the polls he did
not and he's basically been stagnant in
the polls and Elizabeth Warren has seen
this slow
steady increase in the polling data but
Warren hasn't come under attack at all
remember for the first couple of debates
she was on the kiddie stage with a bunch
of candidates nobody cared about she was
on stage she liked Bill DeBlasio and
then finally she made it onto the big
stage in the last debate and Bernie
Sanders decided to lay off of her well
in this debate
nobody laid off of Elizabeth Warren and
she did not handle herself well because
again Elizabeth Warren is too smart not
to know that her plans suck and she
keeps saying that she has plans oh I
have plans I have plans oh so many plans
yes but your plans are garbage and it
was made clear after about 30 seconds on
the debate stage that even Elizabeth
Warren can't defend her own plan she
also says wild and crazy things on a
regular basis that are frankly immoral
hey it all started with the debate about
taxes so she was asked for the one
millionth time whether she was going to
raise middle class taxes the answer of
course is yes she's radically going to
raise middle class taxes and all her
talk about taxing wealth first of all
it's unconstitutional second of all to
morale by taxing people's wealth I
already paid taxes on that stuff lady
right you are going to you're going to
tax me on the stuff that I have already
paid taxes on so if I spend my entire
life building up a nest egg for my
children and then the government's
already going to try and steal that nest
egg when I die you're gonna try and tax
the amount of like so I earn a million
bucks and then I pay half of it to the
government and then I take the rest and
I buy a house with it and then you want
to assess the value of the house and tax
me on the value of the house every year
as a wealth tax how many times can you
take a bite at the same Apple anyway
that's that's just one of Elizabeth
Warren's wild and myriad proposals so
she is asked by one of the debate
moderators last night whether she would
raise taxes on the middle class and she
will not answer the question will you
raise taxes on the middle class for
paper to pay for it yes or no so I have
made clear what my principles are here
and that is costs will go up for the
wealthy and for big corporations and for
hardworking middle-class families costs
will go down that is called avoiding the
question what Elizabeth Warren just did
there that is just avoiding the question
because again the answer is yes your
taxes will go up if you are middle-class
and Bernie Sanders makes this clear
right they went to Bernie Sanders and
Bernie was like yes I won't worry so
taxes of course I will raise your taxes
your overall cost
we'll go down because you'll no longer
have to pay for pudding but your taxes
will go up at least he's honest about it
Elizabeth Warren refuses to say those
words because she knows that that will
be the lead campaign commercial for the
Trump campaign hey and then she gets
slapped over it
but first safety is really important to
me hey I have 24/7 security at this
point thanks to all of the various
threats and so the kind of gear that I
have on my house is extremely
importantly it's got to be top-notch
which is why I rely on ring rings
mission is to make the neighborhood
safer you may already know about their
smart video doorbells and the cameras
that protect millions of people
everywhere I've talked about them on the
show right there ring the doorbell and I
can pick up from Israel and I know who's
at my front door ring helps you stay
connected to your home anywhere in the
world so if there's a package delivery
or a surprise visitor you get an alert
and you're able to see here and speak to
them all from your phone makes me feel
safer more importantly makes my wife
feel safer as a subscriber over here you
have a special offer on a ring welcome
kit available right now at ring comm
slash Bend the kit includes that ring
video doorbell - and a chime Pro which
is what you need to start building that
ring of security around your home today
go to ring.com slash bet again that's
ring.com slash brenda got ring devices
all over our property again making our
property safer which means a lot to me
it'll mean a lot to you as well go check
it out
ring calm / Ben again that's ring Netcom
/ Ben additional terms may apply
so P boo to judge who got pretty
aggressive and feisty in the debate last
night it was one of the things that
early on I thought was attractive about
boo to judges that he seems like a
person who actually has the capacity to
reason ok well he went after her on the
tax issue and it was not pretty for her
Mayor Buddha jesh you say senator Warren
has been quote evasive about how she's
gonna pay for Medicare for all what's
your response well we heard it tonight a
yes or no question that didn't get a yes
or no answer but this is why people here
in the Midwest are so frustrated with
Washington in general and Capitol Hill
in particular your signature senator is
to have a plan for everything except
this boom that is correct
her signature is to have a plan for
everything except for she doesn't know
how to explain her own plans because her
plans stink and then bootie judge goes
on and he explains that her plans are
going to alienate a huge number of
Americans I don't underst
and why you believe the only way to
deliver affordable coverage to everybody
is to obliterate private plans kicking a
hundred fifty million Americans off of
their insurance in four short years when
we could achieve that same big bold goal
and once again we have a president
competing to be president for the day
after Trump Amy Klobuchar goes harder
than booty judge at least Bernie's being
honest here and saying how he's gonna
pay for this and that taxes are gonna go
up and I'm sorry Elizabeth but you have
not said that and I think we owe it to
the American people to tell them where
we're gonna send the invoice ouch and
correct Amy Klobuchar pointing out that
Elizabeth Warren is a liar and by the
way it is a lie when politic politicians
lie to you because they want to make
money off of you and because they want
to gain power off of you this is why
politicians lie to you and it's true
right left and center this is not a
partisan thing you will see Republican
politicians say they're gonna bring jobs
back to your dying town they have no way
of doing so and you'll see Elizabeth
Warren lying lying about middle-class
taxes by simply refusing to answer the
question because the fact is that her
plans are not good they're simply not
good and she wants power anyway Joe
Biden by the way went after Elizabeth
Warren on this as well and again he
scored some points here I'm the single
most important thing facing the American
public I think it's awfully important to
be straight forward with the plan is
going to cost at least thirty trillion
dollars over ten years that is more than
a yearly basis than the entire federal
budget well realistically speaking Joe
Biden is a little wrong it's gonna cost
three-quarters of the federal budget so
he's not totally wrong thirty trillion
dollars over ten years the federal
budget right now is about four trillion
dollars a year so it's a near doubling
of the federal budget and Elizabeth
Warren doesn't have any way to pay for
that and this is the constant theme from
Elizabeth Warren she's either saying
stuff that is so radical that it is
impossible to fact-check it because
she's making moral claims or she is
saying stuff that she herself cannot
back up because the data simply do not
back it up I mean here is one of her
radical proposals so Elizabeth Warren is
asked about jobs and Bernie Sanders has
already claimed that he wants a
universal jobs guarantee and then you
see my boy Andrew yang the only person
with half
brain on stage saying Americans don't
want to work for the federal government
no that's true then Elizabeth Warren
comes in like the kool-aid man just boom
right through the wall a very
mild-mannered Massachusetts kool-aid man
she has read so I mean I guess that
works in any case Elizabeth Warren
explains that what she actually wants to
do is force every corporation in America
to have 40% of its Board elected by the
employees of the corporation that's
that's ridiculous it's ridiculous hey
you think that I'm gonna let the
employees over at the daily wire vote on
their own wages you think that's a thing
where they get a vote that is not a
thing where they get a vote because if
they did get a vote then they would
probably bankrupt the company because
you have a collective action problem in
the companies where you do have
employees voting on their own wages
effectively speaking at the major car
manufacturers for example they basically
bankrupted the car industry through
private unionization and government cram
downs over the course of decades it
turns out that you know who knows how to
run the corporations the people who are
interested in the profits of the
corporation and the business the
business workability of a corporation
not the people who are seeking to suck
money out of the corporation in
short-sighted fashion right now there
are private sector unions that are
willing to work with employers in in
sort of cooperative slash adversarial
fashion with the tug and the poll but
Elizabeth Warren effectively unionizing
every business in America is gonna be a
giant fail and by the way if you really
believe that employees all want to be
unionize you're gonna have to explain
the 7% private sector unionization rate
in this country it turns out that most
employees in this country want to be
able to independently negotiate their
salaries with the bosses in any case
here's the elizabeth warren but the
principle reason has been bad trade
policy the principal reason has been a
bunch of corporations giant
multinational corporations have been
calling the shots on trade giant
multinational corporations that I have
no loyalty to America they have no
loyalty to American workers they have no
loyalty to American consumers they have
no loyalty to American communities they
are loyal only to their own bottom line
I have a plan to fix that and it's
accountable capitalism it says you want
to have one of the giant corporations in
America then by golly
40% of your board of directors should be
elected by your employees that is an
insane violation of freedom of contract
it's an insane violation of freedom of
association
who the hell is Elizabeth Warren to
decide how I run my business she has
never made a dollar not a dollar for me
she has not run my business not in any
way not in any way shape or form Warren
says something similar later
so Warren actually comes forward and she
says she doesn't have a beef with
billionaires and then she explains it in
very much Barack Obama fashion because
Barack Obama actually ripped the speech
off from her years ago she basically
says you didn't build your business
yourself so I'm really shocked at the
notion that anyone thinks I'm qunit is
look I don't have a beef with
billionaires my problem is you made a
fortune in America you had a great idea
you got out there and worked for it good
for you
but you built that fortune in America I
guarantee you built it in part using
workers all of us helped pay to educate
you built it in part getting your goods
to market on roads and bridges all of us
helped pay for you built it at least in
part protected by police and
firefighters all of us helped pay the
salaries for now this is the same exact
argument that that Barack Obama made in
2012 when he said you didn't build that
except guess what all of those things
are being paid for by the people who
create businesses who does she think
pays taxes in this country who who pays
the income tax in this country and by
the way the people who are salaried at
these corporations they get paid they're
not wage slaves they're getting paid and
they are paying taxes in their
neighborhoods and if the corporations
disappear
who do you think is gonna pay all that
local property tax that supports the
school who do you think is gonna pay the
police and the firefighting if she's
shocked people think she's punitive she
is punitive she's deeply punitive I mean
by the way she's not just punitive she's
immoral there's one point during this
debate where Elizabeth Warren actually
suggested in the middle of the debate
and that the rich are not like you and
me Elizabeth Warren is worth 10 million
dollars she's worth money
she literally says the rich are not like
you and me so understand taxing income
is not going to get you where you need
to be the way taxing well
does that the rich are not like you and
me the really really billionaires are
making their money off their accumulated
wealth and it just keeps growing
we need a wealth tax in order to make
investments in the next generation the
rich are not like you and me the rich
are exactly like you and me because you
know what there was a point in my life
where I was certainly not rich and there
will be a point in my life I'm sure
again at which my income is not a rich
person's income
hey people go up and down on the income
spectrum the rich are not just like you
and me the rich are you and me because
you will change your wealth level over
the course of time and taxing wealth is
a way of punishing people who have
already paid their taxes andrew yang
immediately fires back on Elizabeth
Warren he's exactly right senator Warren
is a hundred percent right that were in
the midst of the most extreme
winner-take-all economy in history and a
wealth tax makes a lot of sense in
principle the problem is that it's been
tried in Germany France Denmark Sweden
and all those countries ended up
repealing it because it had massive
implementation problems and did not
generate the revenue that they projected
Andrew yang is exactly right about that
even beta or work gets into the act
attacking Elizabeth Warren I mean when
he went when bado who's an insane person
I mean almost literally in the same
person I mean he suggested last week
that we basically take away tax
exemptions from every religious
institution in America which not only
would take away their tax exemptions as
I talked about on Friday if you listen
to the podcast and not just the clips
but also would set the stage for the
removal of their business licenses and
the non accreditation of school I mean
beta O'Rourke is a radical and a
wild-eyed radical at death but even bado
is looking at Elizabeth Warren going
lady what is wrong with you and Senator
Warren said show me your budget show me
your tax plan and you'll show me your
values she has yet to describe her tax
plan and whether or not that person I
met would see a tax increase under my
administration if you make less than two
hundred and fifty thousand dollars a
year as a family you will not see a tax
increase that family so Warren is a
combination of liar and radical she's a
combination of liar and radical and that
is what we are seeing that's what we saw
on the stage last night it was a very
bad book for Warren now she wasn't the
only one who is radical
the stage the fact that Joe Biden by the
way is seen as a moderate is hilarious
because Joe Biden is not moderate Joe
Biden is not a moderate it's just that
when you compare Trotsky Lenin suddenly
looks like a moderate but Joe Biden said
last night that he would raise the
capital gains tax from what is it 15%
now all the left to 40% and he thinks
that that is not going to have any
impact on wealth earning in the United
States or the stock market you know who
he's taxing when he tax capital gains he
is taxing all of the grandmothers who
have their money in pension funds that
are with mutual funds at Omaha right I
mean that's exactly what's happening and
he's going after not it's not just rich
people in the stock market anymore it's
ridiculous it's ridiculous so the
Democrats are out there just pushing
these radical radical policies and then
they get even more radical and in just a
second we will talk about the Democratic
policies with regard to abortion where
again in Tulsi Gabbard is the only voice
of reason we'll get to that in just one
second first my dad suffers from sleep
apnea just like 1 billion individuals
around the world and you may not even
know you have sleep apnea but then you
go and you get it checked out and you
realize you need a CPAP machine well
CPAP machines keep you alive but they
are really difficult and annoying to
clean they're a pain in the butt and
this is why you need a safe and
effective automated sanitizing solution
it's called so clean it's the world's
first automated CPAP cleaner and
sanitizer so clean kills up to 99.9%
small CPAP germs and bacteria that can
build up in your mask hose and reservoir
it's easy to use you just put the mask
in you close the lid you walk away works
with all the popular CPAP machines as
well as masks so clean uses advanced
technology to sanitize your CPAP
equipment with just the touch of a
button it's a safe healthy way to
breathe cleaner and have a better CPAP
experience again and you'll sleep better
you'll feel healthier right now for our
listeners you get to try so clean
risk-free for 30 nights even shipping is
free so don't wait go to so clean calm
take advantage of this 30 night
risk-free trial you got nothing to lose
and free shipping as well again that is
so clean calm go to so clean calm once
more that is so clean calm go subscribe
over at daily we're calm when you do you
get the rest of this show live you get
the rest of the three-hour show live
because we do two additional hours every
afternoon plus you get all sorts of
other goodies the daily wires
long-awaited app is finally here and it
really is first-rate if you are a
subscriber you can access all of our
contents including articles shows and
more straight from the app all access
get our new and exclusive discussion
features where they can interact
directly with our hosts writers another
special guest in fact I'm doing one of
those a little bit later today the app
is available on Apple and Android so
download today become a subscriber and
come and join the fun go check us out
over a daily wire coming in $99 a year
it gets you the best in all beverage
vessels go check it out right now we are
the largest fastest growing conservative
podcast and radio show in the nation
[Music]
all righty so it wasn't just the
Democrats being radical on economics
they were also being radical on the
social issues as per their usual
arrangement on abortion they were
particularly radical tulsi gabbard
sounded the only dissenting note because
Gabbard said yes there should be some
third trimester restrictions in place
which by the way is a broad spectrum
position in the United States there's
basically one third of Americans who
believe that all abortions should be off
the table and there's like one third of
Americans who believe that no abortions
should be off the table and then there's
like 70 percent of Americans who believe
that some abortion restrictions should
be on the table including third
trimester abortions Tulsi Gabbard said
that during a third trimester abortion
should not be an option unless lifeforce
of your health consequences of women are
at risk good for Tulsi Gabbard for
saying the unsayable but the other
Democrats were certainly not having any
of that again the most amusing candidate
on the stage right now is definitely
common low harris because she's trying
so hard like points for effort a for
effort for Kamala Harris because she's
not going anywhere
she had that one first great debate and
it was her moment her leap to stardom
and then the ground just collapsed
underneath the weight of her and boom
she was just on the ground and ever
since then she has been pledging to turn
herself into Stalin in order to earn
your love she would do anything for love
include liquidating the kulaks in any
case Kamala Harris say about abortion
it's wild she says this my plan is as
followed as follows I for any state that
passes along that violates the
Constitution and in particular roe v
wade our Department of Justice will
review that law to determine if it is
compliant with roe v wade in the
Constitution and if it is not that law
will not go into effect
that's called preclearance you may have
seen that I questioned Brett Kavanaugh
when I was a member of the Senate
Judiciary Committee and asked him as a
nominee to serve on the United States
Supreme Court could he think of any law
that tells a man what to do with his
body and the answer was uh no couple of
things about this particular clip that
are crazy one preclearance is
unconstitutional in preclearance is
unconstitutional
this matter as many other matters the
federal government does not get to act
legislature of the executive branch they
do not get to act as a check on state
legislators that is the job of the
federal judiciary if you believe in the
incorporation doctrine the federal
government generally does not get to act
without the authority to do this on an
executive basis and that that's a wild
usurpation of power and a destruction of
federalism and then her comment that
that there's not a single law that tells
a man what to do with his body try
virtually every law that applies to
human beings right I'm not allowed to
use my body to snack my employees I'm
not allowed to use my body to sell drugs
there are lots of different things are
not allowed to do with your body the
only thing that is different between men
and women when it comes to this is that
men don't have another human being
inside their body unless they're Jeffrey
Dahmer that's not something that you're
supposed to have is inside if you're a
woman you have another human being in
there my wife is pregnant there's a
human in there a human okay and if she
decides to harm that human she's not
just doing something with her body she's
doing something with that human's body
as all of us know
McConnell Harris is a wild human big
Cory Booker also is trying really hard
and get an A for effort for Cory Booker
he's been going nowhere fast he's
beginning some good press well he's
doing yeah but mr. Potatohead
he packed his angry aw he's and he
decided to show and I'm never gonna let
that joke die because I just love it so
Cory Booker he says that not only is he
going to do something about abortion
he's gonna set up get ready for it guys
a cabinet-level position at the White
House to talk about stuff boom take that
pro-life advocates so the way as
president I stays I'm gonna deal with
this is first of all elevating it like
we have with other national crises to a
White House level position and I will
create the office of reproductive
freedom and reproductive rights in the
what in the White House and make sure
that we begin to fight back on a
systematic attempt that's going on for
decades to undermine roe v wade oh
because you need an agency for that oh
like like you haven't been using Health
and Human Services for that Cory Booker
man that guy tries that guy tries my
favorite statement about this was people
to judge his statement about abortion
why because Democrats just lie freely
and openly about what they want the
Supreme Court to be and people
sort of lets the cat out of the bag here
so they keep saying things like we want
justices who represent the values of the
American people and defend the
Constitution we don't just want justices
who defend all of our favorite political
positions and then people do judges like
well well
maybe I'm just gonna appoint justices
you agree totally with everything I
agree with politically what's your
response to the vice president that's
right when I proposed reforming the
Supreme Court some folks said that was
too bold to even contemplate now I'm not
talking about packing the court just
with people who agree with me although I
certainly will appoint people who share
my values for example the idea that
women's reproductive freedom is an
American right okay so um one clause in
that sentence doesn't match with the
other clause in that sentence when he
says I'm not just going to appoint
people who agree with me I'm going to
appoint people who share my values
that's a dude that's people who agree
with you I'm not sure if you know what
agree means but that that would be like
people who agree with you salad stuff
they're from the Democrats probably the
most ironic portion of this debate was
the Syria portion of this debate where
Democrats who cheered wildly as Barack
Obama pulled American troops out of Iraq
leading to the rise of Isis are very
very angry at Donald Trump for pulling
American troops out of certain areas of
Syria leading to the rise of Isis now
Trump's policy is wrong Trump's policy
is bad and as we've seen over the past
few days
president Trump basically announces this
thing and within 24 hours the Kurds are
getting the crap bombed out of them and
now the Kurds are trying to make common
cause Bashar Assad simply says they
don't get annihilated by the Kurds so
this has been going just fantastic by
the Turks this has been going just
phenomenally well but Democrats saying
anything about it
just gonna point out you guys didn't
have a lot to say when it was Barack
Obama losing a victory that had already
been won in Iraq after the surge here
was Joe Biden pretending that he has any
any leverage to talk about foreign
policy Joe Biden has been wrong about
every major foreign policy issue for 30
years every one of the great
disappointments of my adult life
politically speaking was watching Paul
Ryan to bait Joe Biden and Joe Biden
just lying and making things up about
foreign policy like he talked about
tossing the Iranians out of Lebanon
which has never happened like he he's
just he just makes things up so here's
Joe Biden warbling and rambling all over
the stage
I would not have withdrawn the troops
and it would not have drawn the
additional thousand troops are in Iraq
which are in retreat now being fired on
by a shot by Assad's people and the
President on stage saying if those if
those Isis folks escape from the prisons
are in they'll only go to Europe or
won't effective it has been the most
shameful thing that I've that any
president has done in modern history in
terms of foreign policy
oh really Joe Biden just got just gonna
but like it's bad I agree it's bad but
your boss pulled out of Iraq and called
Isis the JV squad and within two years
Isis had taken over a vast swath of
territory larger than the size of Great
Britain so yeah you were there for that
dude and you stink at foreign policy
terrible at foreign policy there's a lot
of it I mean the more of this debate you
saw the more you saw that Democrats just
cannot be trusted with power just cannot
be trusted with power and stumble all
over themselves when asked about the
implications of their own policies my
favorite moment in terms of somebody who
was caught out on his own policy then
had to backtrack his own policy but then
sort of admitted that his own policy
does what his critics say it will do was
bait oh so again bait oh it's so funny
because when beta is sort of like bootie
judge their initial appeal was that they
were not crazy and then in order to
appeal to Bernie Sanders's base Bernie
Sanders his base it's like the ring of
power everybody thinks they can grasp it
and by grasping that ring of power they
can finally bring righteousness to
Gondor but instead all that ends up
happening is that they get warped like
Denethor and start setting themselves on
fire it's crazy right they they go for
that Bernie Sanders power base and they
can't take it away from Bernie because
bernie is Gollum Bernie's never letting
that power base go away that ring is on
Bernie he's old he's decrepid he maybe
he had a heart it doesn't matter he is
still wandering around being Gollum
grabbing at the ring and he's never
gonna let that ring Bell right he's
gonna go down into the volcano with that
ring doesn't matter all the other
Democrats keep trying to grasp the ring
and for a moment in time they will have
the ring and then the ring will will
utterly destroy them so beta O'Rourke is
one of those people he started off as a
look at me I'm a moderate I can unify
people and I talk happy talk and it's
great and I have very weird arms and a
movement arms up and down
I don't know I'm doing a sort of weird
southern accent there except that
is sort of a weird used-car salesman who
seems like you should speak like that in
any case it'll work brah beta so beta
has been saying for now months that he
wants to remove every AR in America
every every single Armalite rifle every
every single rifle that works in America
that is not a bolt-action World War one
or a rifle he wants to remove and he
wants to make it illegal to sell them
and he wants to remove them the existing
ones right through a gun buyback and
people in saying so what are gonna do go
door-to-door and take people's guns away
and there's like no bra I'm not gonna do
that
people are just going to abide like the
dude they're just going to abide by the
law hey so beta was asked about that
last night and he had to walk back his
own statements 40 different ways we
don't go door to door to do anything in
this country to enforce the law I expect
Republicans Democrats gun owners non-gun
owners alike follow the law if someone
does not turn in an ar-15 or an ak-47
one of these weapons of war or brings
out in public and embraces it in an
attempt to intimidate as we saw when we
were at Kent State recently then that
weapon will be taken from them if they
persist there will be other consequences
from law enforcement
so bado should just know those other
consequences from law enforcement and
involve police officers coming to your
house and arresting you and going door
to door he literally says there if
someone does not turn in in ar-15 or an
ak-47 dot-dot-dot
there will be there will be other
consequences from law enforcement sounds
a lot like people going door to door and
taking your guns away bado cuz how else
they can know whether you turned in the
gun again the Democrats do not want to
live with the consequences of their own
policy and the funniest part of the
debate last night was when other
Democrats were pointing this out so Pete
Buddha judge pointed this out to bado
@p Buddha judge who is the kid in school
who always brings the Polish to Apple to
the teacher his teacher's pet but
Peabody Judge is correct here and he
attacks panel cuz Bailey was doing this
whole I'm I'm brave dude cuz I want to
take your guns I'm so brave I mean I'm
not gonna do it but I'm gonna make other
people do it and maybe I won't make
other people do it but maybe I'll talk
about it a lot and people do judge was
like come on come on
promised in the polls the problem is the
policy and I don't need lessons from you
on courage political or personal
everyone on this stage is determined to
get something done everyone on this
stage recognizes release I thought we
did that the problem is not other
Democrats who don't agree with your
particular idea of how to handle this
whoo people who decide getting feisty
they're getting very very feisty so that
was a delicious moment also again I have
to go back to Connell Harrison again
points for effort for Camilla Harris
she's trying so hard she desperately
wants your love and she desperately
wants her attention okay so personal
note right now in my life my son is
incredibly fussy right we went all the
way across the world and he has been
lacking sleep and this means that he is
yelling a lot and he is fussing a lot
and that means that he's getting a lot
of attention because it's difficult to
deal with a screaming three-year-old who
refuse to sit in his car seat when
you're about to go on an hour-long drive
well this has prompted my five-year-old
daughter to also begin fussing and
screaming and she will literally come
and yell at me and then she will say I'm
yelling because I want your attention
because she's smart enough to understand
exactly what it is that she is doing
Kamala Harris is my five-year-old right
all the other Democrats all the other
Democrats on stage are getting some sort
of attention elizabeth warren has gotten
attention and commonly harris is
standing in the corner screaming that
she is not getting attention screaming
that she's not getting attention
my favorite attack from so Harris went
after Warren right Warren is getting all
the attention for some reason because
the media love a boring really
really condescending Harvard law
professor who has plans that don't stack
up in any real way yet they love that
that is their favorite makes them feel
smart and calmly Harris's getting tired
of all this so she is my daughter coming
in and saying I want attention I'm gonna
scream in your face until I get it and
she just blows Elizabeth Warren's hair
back with this one senator Warren I just
want to say that I was surprised to hear
that you did not agree with me that on
this subject of what should be the rules
around corporate responsibility for
these big tech companies when I called
on Twitter to suspend Donald Trump's a
account that you did not agree and I
would I would urge you to join me oh man
that is so that is cringe-worthy
cringeworthy from Kamala Harris hey her
very very serious program to ban Donald
Trump from Twitter and save the world by
not allowing you to see Donald Trump's
tweets oh the heroism oh that oh the
absolute bravery standing up to
Elizabeth Warren that way slow clap for
, her slow clap for the death of her
campaign slow clap
oh man and Elizabeth Warren's like
really this is your line of attack like
look at me I got 29 lines of attack no
one here has even mentioned that I
pretended to be a Native American for 20
years my Kamala that's your line right
you're a legitimate person of color I am
NOT a legitimate person of color you
could just go after me on that basis and
you're coming after me with and then you
said Trump should be on Twitter boom
roasted really come where's the
definition of trying too hard in the
dictionary under under trying too hard
under pressing is just a picture of
Kamala Harris looking sad okay so this
entire debate closes with Joe Biden
getting into it with Bernie Sanders and
Elizabeth Warren and people are giving
points to Sanders and Warren for this
but frankly I don't think it's justified
so Biden concludes by pointing out guys
I'm the only one on the stage who's
actually done anything all of you guys
sit here and you talk and you're useless
I'm gonna say something that is probably
gonna offend some people here but I'm
the only one in the stage has gotten
anything really big done from the
Violence Against Women Act to making
sure that we passed the Affordable Care
Act to be in a position where we in fact
took almost a ninety billion dollar Act
that would that kept us from going in a
depression making us in a Podesta
position where I was able and Rove
excuse me able to end the issue of gun
sales in terms of assault weapons and so
the question is who is best prepared we
all have good ideas the question is how
who's gonna be able to get it done okay
and then Biden says some of us have
vague plans and he's asked so who's
vague and he sort of says Lorne and then
Warren fires back and she says this I am
deeply grateful to President Obama who
fought so hard to make sure
that agency was passed into law and I am
deeply grateful to every single person
who fought for it and who helped pass it
into law
Warren is angry because Biden said that
he was the one who passed the consumer
finance Protection Bureau at that that
is not an Elizabeth Warren achievement
she wasn't in the Senate at the time
Warren tried to fire back by going over
his head to Obama not sure that it
worked particularly great Bernie Sanders
tried this also and Sanders attack again
is more damaging because Sanders is more
pure of heart
if useless in practice Bernie Sanders
says this I think this is a good friend
you got the disastrous war in Iraq done
you got a bankruptcy bill which is
hurting middle-class families all over
this country frankly I'm surprised
Warren didn't go that direction but she
didn't but Bernie Sanders is obviously
the purest weapon out there at this
point so what is the final take away bad
night for the Democrats Elizabeth Warren
is the front runner and she does not
look particularly strong and Trump is
gonna hit her a lot harder than any of
the other Democrats did so if you're a
Democrat right now Bank on impeachment
because if you don't impeach this guy if
you don't come up with something
stronger then you've got in terms of
this campaign he's gonna get reelected
because so far you're presenting nothing
now he could still blow it himself I
mean as we've seen over the past several
weeks Donald Trump is fully capable of
blowing an election himself by being bad
at this but Democrats are not gonna win
this on the strength of their own
platform not the way they were last
night because it was ugly okay we don't
have time for things I like in things I
hate so instead we will be back here
tomorrow with all sorts of more material
and updates and all sorts of goodies for
a so stick around for two more hours
later this afternoon or show up tomorrow
for more i'm ben shapiro this is the
bench bureau show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Robert Sterling directed by Mike joiner
executive producer Jeremy boring senior
producer Jonathan hey our supervising
producer is Mathis Glover and our
technical producer is Austin Stevens
assistant director Pavo wide outski
edited by Adam sy events audio is mixed
by Mike Cora Mina hair and makeup is by
Joshua Olvera production assistant Nick
Sheehan the Ben Shapiro show is a daily
wire production copyright daily wire 20
hey everyone its Andrew Klavan host of
the Andrew Clavin show sparks flew at
the Democrat debate last night
especially after I stuck my finger in
the light socket hoping to make it all
end
who won besides Donald Trump my answer
will surprise you
plus we'll have the mailbag on the
Andrew Klavan truck I'm Andrew plate
[Music]